I want to write an article about
champagne that focuses on the fact that
Prosecco from Italy is now a good
alternative for a portion of the price I
want you to historically reference other
times in history when something was the
establishment and a product came along
that was equal of quality but a fraction
of the price and speak to it in a manner
that helps people understand that
quality of flavor is subjective but
price is not enter the prompting
wrote a very good article
for the London Times about Prosecco and
champagne
put in and then I'm gonna read it and
I'm going to add 10 more sentences
more sentences
Timothy of the writer and the ability of
the editor becomes a new form of a human
being
just literally talked out to you
hang on